l'été 2013 est marquée notamment par
deux événements majeurs aux antipodes
l'un de l'autre se sont tout d'abord des
émeutes à trappes à la mi juillet à
l'origine un contrôle d'une femme
portant le voile intégral qui tourne mal
son mari est interpellé pour avoir tenté
d'étrangler un policier des jeunes
reproche aux policiers des propos et des
attitudes islamophobe et le passage du
tour de france qui pour son centenaire
est passé à saint quentin en yvelines
non loin du vélodrome qui sera
officiellement inaugurée le 30 janvier
prochain ultime étape entre versailles
et les champs elysées c'était le 21
juillet dernier les coureurs sont donc
passés dans les rue de montigny
notamment bondée pour l'occasion avec
des fans qui supportait des coureurs
venus de très loin à ccc ont laissé mon
père est super faim depuis que je suis
née ont laissé chaque année
un mois de septembre marquée aussi par
la mise en place de la réforme scolaire
dans les yvelines parmi les villes qui
ont fait ce choix celle de trappes 300
1667 yvelinois en faire leur rentrée et
attrapes cela s'est passé de façon
paisible est venu nous dire la première
adjointe jeanine mari un bilan sera tiré
en ce début d'année 2014
les horaires ont été modifiés retardé de
vingt minutes le matin la pause
méridienne est inchangé il termine à 16
heures case de l'après midi qui peuvent
rester jusqu'à 16h30 ce quart d'heure
est un quart d'heure offert aux parents
c'est gratuit et puis après la volée se
continuent comme elles se passait
précédemment un temps consacré au goûter
aux le saut et puis les activités qui
vont commencer avec les prestataires de
service lundi prochain toujours à
trappes 80 mille véhicules traversent
chaque jour la nationale 10 elle sera
bientôt couverte sur une longueur de 400
mètres environ le projet n'est pas
nouveau mais il manquait les fonds pour
le concrétiser et c'est chose faite un
courrier signé du ministre des
transports qui confirme une volonté
d'avancer
un début du mois de septembre marquée
également par des inaugurations d'abord
à elancourt une nouvelle résidence pour
les étudiants a ouvert offrant 160 et un
logement à saint-cyr-l'ecole lycée
professionnel jean perrin a inauguré ses
nouveaux locaux après huit ans de
chantier le président ps de la région
ile de france a fait le déplacement pour
couper le ruban 34 millions d'euros du
conseil régional ont été investis la
réhabilitation permet l'établissement de
consolider ces formations notamment
celles d'optique lunetterie c'est le
seul lycée public du département à
proposer cette filière à montigny le
bretonneux c'est la fin des travaux de
rénovation de la gare la salle des pas
perdus et doté d'une signalétique plus
clair l'espace a été décroise sonné avec
25000 usagers par jour et sans
rénovation importante depuis 1975 les
locaux étaient devenus plus que vétuste
des travaux à hauteur de 1 8 million
d'euros financé en moitié par la région
ile de france et la sncf
les aménagements extérieurs devraient se
prolonger jusqu'en 2017 et puis en ce
mois de septembre des événements
également politique la venue tout
d'abord d'arnaud montebourg le ministre
du redressement productif au siège de
cassidian à elancourt c'était une
première visite pour le ministre tour de
la nouvelle france industrielle en ce
début du mois de septembre arnaud
montebourg a annoncé 34 plan de
reconquête industrielle
le but rendre les secteurs innovants
plus concurrentiel de marché ont ici été
évoqué la cybersécurité et le
développement du réseau 4g nous
investissons là où nous pouvons obtenir
les créations d'emplois l'art de la
guerre
comme disait tous les stratèges
militaires c'est de concentrer nos
forces sur les points forts et non pas
les disperser sur nos points faibles lui
aussi est un personnage très attendue en
ce début de rentrée politique pierre
bédier première séance du conseil
général en ce 30 septembre et retour en
politique pour celui qui avait occupé le
fauteuil de président de 2005 à 2009
2009 date à laquelle il avait abandonné
son poste après avoir été condamné à
trois ans de privation de droits
civiques pour corruption passive et
recel d'abus de biens sociaux pendant la
séance l'élu ump est apparue concentrée
très silencieux et n'a pas pris part aux
débats et puis il a aussi été question
d'intercommunalité en ce mois de
septembre au 1er janvier 2014 et les
villes doivent s'associer en
intercommunalité mais celle constituée
de plaisir villepreux et les
clayes-sous-bois démarre bien mal la mer
udi des clayes-sous-bois véronique côté
millard a remis en cause ce mariage à
trois jugés inutiles et coûteux les deux
autres mères font cause commune et
tendent la main à leur troisième
comparse un feuilleton qui ne fait que
débuter